[Música]
Boa noite, minhas amigas, meus amigos,
para mais uma live dos apoiadores do
canal. Sejam muito bem-vindos. É um
prazer estar falando com vocês novamente
depois de 14 dias aí sem termos a nossa
live semanal. Realmente eu tentei fazer
semana passada, mas não foi possível por
conta de eu estar 4 horas para trás e o
hotel tinha um Wi-Fi horrível. Isso até
o que eu fiquei na segunda semana da
viagem. Bem, à medida que vocês forem
entrando, por favor, vão aí dando um alô
para eu acompanhar
vocês e a gente poder estar respondendo
as dúvidas, tá? Hoje tem bastante dúvida
para responder, então eu já vou começar,
mas conforme vocês forem entrando, por
favor, vão dando o
alô. Deixa eu avisar aqui no canal, no
grupo, né, que já começamos.
Bem, eh, deixa eu apresentar aqui para
vocês a tela com as
perguntas. Esse
aqui.
Pronto. Primeira pergunta da rua Elita.
Ferretina em 28 é considerado anemia?
Bem, primeiro, antes de responder isso,
vamos relembrar o que que é ferritina. É
uma proteína que armazena ferro no
organismo, funciona como reservatório
desse mineral fundamental paraa produção
dos glóbulos vermelhos, né, e também pro
transporte de oxigênio. Esse nível de 28
não é necessariamente anemia, mas indica
sim uma deficiência de ferro no estágio
inicial.
Hoje mesmo atendi uma menina de 14 anos
que estavam com uma ferritina mais ou
menos esse valor aí e passei ferro para
ela, tá? Anemia a gente diagnostica de
forma
direta através da avaliação da
hemoglobina e do hematócto, né, e não
diretamente pela ferritina. Mas mesmo
que não tem anemia, é importante a gente
tratar ferritina baixa, porque ela é uma
causa de fadiga. Ela pode ser uma causa
inclusive de problemas escolares em
adolescentes, né? Porque a descência de
ferro pode gerar realmente problemas aí
cognitivos. Então é ideal manter a
ferritina em mulheres eh pelo menos 50,
tá? Entre 50 e 80 seria um bom nível de
ferina paraa mulher.
Muitas mulheres têm deficiência de ferro
leve, podem ter queda de
cabelo, fadiga, queda cognitiva, unha
frágil, né? né? Então esse corpo que o
corpo prioriza o pouco ferro que tá
disponível para as funções vitais e
deixa outras
necessidades em segundo
plano. Então é interessante você
correlacionar essa ferritina de 28 com
outros exames como a capacidade
de eh de transferina, de saturação de
transferina, a proteína ser reativa, né,
a própria hemograma, né, que tem
hemoglobina
hematócto, já que a ferritina pode estar
falsamente normal em caso de inflamação
ou
infecção. Então, em mulheres é muito
comum a ferina está baixa por questão de
sangramento menstrual. também por uma
absorção intestinal que acontece em
pessoas que têm inflamação intestinal ou
doença celíaca e pessoas que tem uso
prolongado de
antiinflamatórios. Então é interessante
para aqueles não veganos aumentar a
ingestão de alimentos ricos em ferro
como carnes vermelhas, também as folhas
verdes escuras como cob espinafre, asa
leguminosas como feijão e lentilha e
associar com a vitamina C que ajuda na
absorção do ferro, tá?
Então, utilizar aí frutas ricas e
vitamina C para auxiliar na absorção do
ferro, que a vitamina C ajuda a absorver
o ferro e evitar consumir café, chá
preto ou leite durante as refeições,
porque pode inibir a absorção de
ferro. Em termos de suplementação, a
gente prefere usar o bisglicinato de
ferro. Então, são formas que ten uma
dissorção maior, né?
E o uso também de eh abordagens
naturais, como uso de clorofila ou
espirulina pode ajudar na absorção do
ferro. Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Não tem ninguém acompanhando ao
vivo. Vem continuar
aqui. A próxima pergunta aqui é da
também da Roelita. Quais são as melhores
cepas de probióticos para se tomar após
usar a fosfomicina, que é um
antibiótico, e por quanto tempo?
A fos homicída é um antibiótico que foi
desenvolvido há relativamente pouco
tempo, por volta aí de 15
[Música]
anos. É um antibiótico de amplo
espectro. Ele é muito utilizado para
infecções
urinárias e realmente se você utilizar
ele por muito tempo, pode impactar de
forma significativa no equilíbrio da
microbiota intestinal.
Então, a gente pode utilizar as cpras
probióticas para ajudar a reparar o
intestino após o uso do
antibiótico, especialmente pessoas que
têm diarreia após uso de
antibiótico. Então, as cepas que mais
são estudadas para isso é a lactobacíos
raminosos, a sacaromises
bard, o bif do bactérium
lactis, né? Então, esses três aí, vou
repetir, lactob lactobacíos raminosos,
lacaromicis, blarde e bifobactérium
lactis. O lraminosos, né, o lactobacilos
raminosos, ele tem uma resistência
natural a vários antibióticos, incluindo
a fosfumicina, e ajuda a reduzir a
adesão de bactérias nocivas ao epitério
intestinal. Já o stafilococos, aliás,
desculpa, o sacaromicesis bullard, que é
um tipo de levedura, né, o fungo
probiótico, ele atua neutralizando as
toxinas bacterianas e modulando a
resposta imunológica. Então, ele é muito
útil para prevenir casos de
infecções eh pelo clostídio, né, o
clustrídeio difícil.
Já o perfito bactério lax, ele estimula
a produção de ácidos grásos de cadeia
curta que são essenciais paraa
regeneração da barreira intestinal.
Também tem estudos recentes mostrando o
papel do bacilus clause, que é um tipo
de
probiótico diferente, que a gente chama
de SFO, né, que são os probióticos de
solo,
né, e ele tem também essa característica
de formar esporos, né, que são
resistentes ao soco gástrico. Isso
garante maior sobrevivência no trato
gastrointestinal.
Então essa cepa
bassilus clause é utilizada
frequentemente em combinação com
lactobacilos acidófilos e o lactobacilos
plantar.
E a suplementação deve ser feita de
quatro a seis semanas com os
probióticos, né, após o término do
antibiótico. Em caso de tispiose
persistente, que tem
flatulência, alterações no hábito
intestinal, intolerências alimentares, o
uso pode ser prolongado por 60 a 90
dias.
E é interessante administrar os
probióticos com intervalo mínimo de 3
horas após a dose do antibiótico, caso
esteja tomando a antibiótico, para
evitar a inativação das cepas benéficas.
E você pode também estar ingerindo
alimentos fermentados, como é o caso do
quefi, do cubo chá, do chucrute, de
vegetais fermentados em geral e das
fibras prebióticas, né, que é o inhame,
a biomassa de banana verde, a fibra de
acá, picílio para nutrir as bactérias
intestinais.
OK? Próxima pergunta da Ângela. Como
baixar o fibrinogênio?
H, o que que é o fibrinogênio? é uma
proteína produzida pelo fígado, que é
essencial para a conagulação do sangue.
E quando seus níveis estão elevados,
pode indicar inflamação, estresse
metabólico ou risco aumentado de dois
cardiovasculares. Então, para reduzir de
forma natural, integrativa, primeiro tem
que fazer uma diatante antiinflamatória,
dormir bem, tomar bastante água, tratar
a inflamação crônica também, tá? Que
supravesante mais utiliza o ômega-3, né?
o a
natoquinase, o
pquenol, a ômega-3 tem ação
anticoagulante, tem ação defamatória
também, ajuda a modular a produção de
fibrinogênio. A natoquinase, que é a
enzima derivada do NATO atô, também tem
ação fibrinolítica. Ela seria na quebra
de coágulos e na redução da proteína,
né,
fibrinogênio. Então, esses são os
principais e também o piquongenal que é
extraído da casca do piero marítimo
francês, que também tem uma ação
antiinflamatória e
anticoagulante. Temos de alimento,
frutas vermelhas tão ricas e
antioxidantes, vegetais de modo geral,
especiarias como cúrcuma e
gengibre, cortar os alimentos
inflamatórios, o controle de estresse
crônico, meditação e yoga, atividade
física regular
moderada, cortar o tabagismo, se for o
caso, e tratar doenças crônicas que
podem estar alimentando esse
fibrinogêno, que é o caso da artrite
crônica, da
artriteide, infecção excelente
resistência insulina, tudo isso pode
aumentar o fibrinogênio,
tá?
Outros suplementos que podem ajudar,
vitamina C,
[Música]
resveratrol e também medir a
homocisteína, porque ela muitas vezes
ela aumenta junto com o fibrinogêno, se
tiver aumentado também fazer uso de
vitaminas do complexo B, de colina, de
naque, de glicina para baixar oa se for
o
caso. Próxima pergunta também da Ângela.
O meu é
411. Deixa eu vou ter que olhar aqui na
fonte da pergunta porque eu não sei se
tá esquisito essa pergunta. Até foi
quebrada no
meio. Mas foi assim mesmo. Pergunta. O
meu é
411. Não sei o que tá fal tudo que ele
tá falando aqui. A proteína ser reativa.
O trassencio 0,1 cistena de 4,9. Áo
úrico de 3,3. Ferritina de 147. A por B,
apo A.
A relação apoio por B
0,6 colesterol total
HDL 3,2 deve ser 32,
né? Na relação colesteral total HDL.
Entendi aqui 3,2 a relação LDL HDL de 2
triglicerídios HDL de
08. Não sei porque o fibrinogênio está
tão elevado. Ah, tá. É a continuação da
pergunta anterior. O fibrinogênio está
em 411.
Bem, Angela, eh, eu não costumo
responder perguntas assim com exames
individuais, tá? Eu já expliquei isso em
vários momentos anteriores e também tá
lá na no grupo, né? Tá na descrição do
grupo. Eu vou falar em modos gerais, tá?
Porque eu não posso fazer diagnóstico
dessa maneira aqui,
[Música]
tá? O que eu posso te dizer é que essa
mocistena não tá alta. Ela tá abaixo de
seis,
tá? E a ferritina pode estar um pouco
alta, sim.
Então, no seu caso, você tem que
investigar eh possíveis causas para essa
essa
inflamação. Investiga especialmente
inflamações silenciosas como doença
autoimune, resistência a insulina,
disbiose intestinal, exposição a
toxinas, estresse oxidativo,
né? Até mesmo fatores genéticos que
possam aumentar a produção do
fibrinogênio.
OK? Já falamos aqui dos suplementos para
baixar fibridongênio, né?
Se você tiver algum problema aí
de sobrecarga na função hepática, é
interessante usar cinmarina, mas tem que
fazer investigação mais aprofundada para
chegar nessa conclusão, tá? O chavete
também pode
ajudar, OK?
Esse perfil lipídico que você colocou
aqui, ele não indica necessariamente um
alto risco
cardiovascular. E outra estratégia que
você pode estar utilizando, caso você
tenha outros fatores de risco pro
sistema cardiovascular, seria usar o
óleo de alho e o gicobilo. OK?
Ah, mais uma pergunta da Ângela aqui.
Costumo ver os seus vídeos e tomo
suplementos por si, por ti, né? Deve ser
por ti sugeridos, porque eu tenho 74
anos. Pratico exercício e alimentação
balanceada, tenho peso normal. Por teu
conselho, comecei há 10 dias, desculpa,
há dias a tomar 100 mg de natoquinase.
Sim, uma boa ideia até por causa do do
fibrinogênio, né? Ah, 100 mg de
natoquináise pela manhã em jejum por
causa fibrinogênio. Sim. Fez bem, Angela
fez bem fazer isso daí.
Tá próxima pergunta do Antônio
Renato. Tem ninguém acompanhando ao vivo
mesmo?
[Música]
Vamos lá. Galinha caipira, deixa de ser
se comer milho manipulado
geneticamente? Não. O que define a
galinha caipira é principalmente a
alimentação, né? Eh, e a maneira como
ela é criada.
Se a galinha for manipulada
geneticamente pela Embrapa, por exemplo,
ela pode ser transformada em caipira?
Não, não, não dá para fazer isso. Mas se
ela fizer alimentação ancestral, com
certeza a carne dela vai ser melhor, vai
ser mais
saudável. Ou fica sempre própria? Não,
se tiver alimentado de forma correta,
não fica imprópria. Não tem uma granja
que alega a ser caipira, mas a
alimentação das galinhas dela tem os
seguintes ingredientes: soja, calcário,
calcítico, organil absorvente para
mitocina do milho, pigmento não sei que
tipo e outra substância chamada núcleo,
não sei o que é. Com esses ingredientes
é caipira? Hum. Não, não é bem caipira
não. O farela de coco substituir a soja
é tão nutritivo
quanto? Ah, eu acho melhor o farelo de
coco do que a soja, até porque a soja
que eles usam não é fermentada. Quais
alimentos um criador orgânico que crie
tanto para uso doméstico como comercial
deve usar com segurança? Se a galinha é
criada em confinamento no quintal de
casa, mas ela recebe luz solar? Não, se
tá sendo criado num quintal, eu não
chamaria de confinamento, não, tá? É
finalmente quando fica dando aquelas
granjas lá naquele cubículo,
né? E tem alimentação orgânica, ela pode
ser considerada em segunda medicina
integrativa
caipira, tá? O que define uma galinha
caipira? É principalmente o sistema de
criação livre, tá? Alimentação
diversificada do solo, né? Alimentação
ancestral das
galinhas. E ela será criada livre, tá?
Esse escândalo, esse é o principal
fator. Se uma galinha ela caipira, ela
consumiu o milho geneticamente
modificado, ela não chega a perder
automaticamente o título de caipira, né?
Porque como eu falei, tá mais
relacionado ao sistema de criação do que
a origem do alimento, mas modifica sim a
qualidade da carne desse frango, certo?
No padrão integrativo, o uso de
transgênico para esse tipo de galinha
seria
proibido. Então, evite de você consumir
a carne de galinha que usa a esse tipo
de ração, tá, do milho, especialmente
milho modificado
transênico, que e geralmente tem
bastante resíduo de
agrotóxico em relação ao geneticamente
modificado, né, para crescer mais
rápido, digamos assim, né, ela não vai é
considerada a caipira, mesmo que seja
criada solta, porque a essência caipira
está na alimentação eh e na genética
ancestral, tá? Incluindo a adaptação
natural ao ambiente, a resistência à
doença sem intervenções
artificiais, tá? Então, evite essa
galinha caipira aí que você falou que
come soja, milho, calcário. Isso aí não
é não é alimentação de galinha caipira,
não. Então, priorize uma galinha caipira
que tenha na sua alimentação milho não
transgênico, farelo de coco, folhas
verdes, insetos, resto de alimentos
orgânicos, tá? Tem uns aditivos
sintéticos.
Falando um pouquinho mais do farela de
coco, né, que você colocou como
substituto da soja, ele contém 22% de
proteína bruta, que é menos que a soja,
mas é rico em fibras e ácidos gros
benéficos e não tem os os antinutrientes
da soja,
tá?
Outras alternativas para essas galinhas
seria farinha de castanha de caju, larva
de inseto e leguminosa, como feijão
gandur. Então, a alimentação segura para
criadores orgânicos seria grãos não
transgênicos como milho, sojo, sorgo,
perdão, o arango, proteínas naturais com
farela de coco que você comentou,
farinha de castanhas, minhoca e larva de
tenébrio, que é o besouro da farinha,
suplementos minerais como casca de ovo
triturada, cinza de madeira que tem
potássio e algas marinhas que tem iodo,
vegetais frescos como folhas de
mandioca, abóbora capinha elefante e
evitar de tipos como curantes,
absorventes e promotores do
crescimento. Se e voltando aquele
assunto da galinha criada em quintal, se
a galinha são criadas em quintal com
acesso à luz solar e alimentação
orgânica, a ela pode ser considerada
assim caipira, mesmo que seja criada em
em quintal, tá?
contando que tem espaço suficiente para
ciscar, banho de areia e expressão de
comportamentos naturais das
galinhas. Próxima pergunta aqui. Qual
raça de galinha caipira você recomenda?
O tema específico. Quando a galinha
caipira ingere cobras pequenas ou
insetos venenosos, esses alimentos não
impactam negativamente a qualidade da
carne e ovo e pode assim transmitir
doenças.
Bem, dentre asas disponíveis tem a
Embrapa 051, né, que destaca-se como
mais recomendada para sistemas
caipiras. Ela foi desenvolvida pela
Embrapa, Suínos e Aves, essa raça
híbrida BRAPA 051. Ela combina
rusticidade e alta produtividade. Ela
adapta-se bem, adapta-se bem a ambientes
abertos, exige menos intervenções como
rações industrializadas ou vacinas de
excesso. A postura de ovos começa com 21
semanas, com produção de até 345 ovos
por
ciclo. Tem uma carne saborosa de textura
firme. Então são características que
tornam ela ideal para pequenos
produtores e criações caseiras. Outras
opções são a carijó, que é conhecida por
sua resistência a diferentes climas e
produção consistente de ovos. E a IS
Brown, Isa Brown, tá? De origem
norte-americana, que também se adapta
bem ao sistema caipira e oferece alta
eficiência na
postura. Quanto à gestão de cobras
pequenas ou insetos venenosos pelas
galinhas, é interessante você entender
que esses animais possuem mecanismos
digestivos. robustos, é capaz de
neutralizar muitas toxinas. No entanto,
o consumo frequente de presas
peçohentas, como certas serpentes ou
insetos, pode sim eventualmente causar
riscos. Então, toxinas acumuladas no
organismo da galinha podem migrar pros
ovos e músculos, embora caso de
contaminação humana seja raro, tá?
Então, para minimizar esse risco,
recomenda-se manter o ambiente de
criação livre de áreas propícias à
proliferação de animais peessonhentos.
Então isso não é um problema na prática
comum, não, tá?
Mas evite a criação dessas galinhas em
áreas de mato alto ou acúmulo de entúho,
que vai favorecer esses bichos
pensoentes, e oferecer também uma dieta
balanceada com grãos, verduras e
suplementos naturais, como é o caso a
semente de abóbora ou linha, que vai
ajudar a fortalecer o sistema
imunológico das
aves. A inclusão de probióticos
naturais, como iogurte não adotsado na
alimentação das galinhas, também melhora
a saúde intestinal dessas aves, enquanto
que plantas como alho e gengibre
adicionados à água agem como
antiparasitários e anti inflamatórios. O
manejo molecular das aves é possível e
enfatiza a suplementação com minerais
como zinco e selênio que vai ajudar na
detoxificação hepática das aves e
reduzindo acúmulo de substâncias
prejudiciais. Tá?
Então, respondendo a sua
pergunta, então, eh, recomenda-se que a
Embrapa 051 é a opção mais versátil,
seguido pelas outras opções que eu já
comentei aqui, a Carijó e a Isa Brown.
OK, Dr. Alan, o RB, Dr. Ribeiro fala que
a nossa
saúde é influenciada pelo que nosso
alimento, pelo que nosso alimento, como
eu não sou adepto de nenhuma religião
que restringja alimentos, mas a Bíblia
fala dos alimentos puros e impuros, mas
é dito que não é mais pecado comer
alimentos impuros. Mas no entanto, em
uma rápida pesquisa, vi que os alimentos
impuros
come quando eles quando lhes é oferecido
carne como porco, por exemplo, que mesmo
criado em confinamento com ração, se um
pintinho ou uma galinha entra nesse
confinamento, não hesita em matar e
comer a
galinha. E os pintinhos e se e se
possível comem até carne humana. Você tá
falando que os porcos comem de tudo.
Eles comem de tudo, sim. É
[Música]
verdade. E é seguinte, se um pouco no
confinamento come um pintinho e alguns
dias ele é abatido e vendido a sua
carne, pode trazer risco paraa saúde
humana? No interior, as pessoas têm
receio de comer carne de porco, sem
saber se o porco se alimentou com
somente grãos e ser alimentado durante
dias pela família. essas pessoas estão
certas no seu raciocínio. Vi que a
doença da vaca louca surgiu por causa
que estava dando pó de osso misturado
com ração. Isso procede. Vamos lá. Tem
muita coisa aqui,
[Música]
né? Sim. É muito importante a forma como
os animais são criados e alimentados na
saúde humana, né? A dieta dos porcos é
importante também as condições de
confinamento, isso pode influenciar
diretamente na segurança da carne.
Então, se um porco criado em
confinamento consumir pintinhos ou
outros animais, isso pode representar
riscos, sim, né? Porque porcos são
animais naturalmente onívoros, eles
comem de tudo. Mas quando submetidos a
práticas de canibalismo ou alimentados
com proteínas de origem animal crua ou
mal processada, aumenta a chance de
transmissão de algumas doenças, de
alguns patógenos, como é o caso de
salmonela, parasita como atênia, que é
causadora da citistercose e até vírus.
E também o estresse gerado pelo
confinamento extremo pode comprometer o
sistema imunológico dos animais,
favorecendo infecções que, por sua vez,
exigem maior uso de antibióticos que a
prática contribui paraa resistência
bacteriana. O receio das pessoas do
interior sobre a alimentação dos pocos é
justificável, tá? que apesar da criação
moderna em confinamento priorizar rações
da base de grãos para controlar a
qualidade, o acesso a subprodutos
animais não
inspecionados ou resíduos contaminados
pode introduzir sim toxinas e agentes
patogênicos. Por exemplo, a cistercose,
que é rara em ambientes
controlados, pode ainda ocorrer se
houver falha de higiene ou no manejo.
Meu pai mesmo tem neurociscose, porque
quando ele era
criança há 70 anos atrás, ele teve
contato com carne aí de
porco, infelizmente que não foi bem
criado. Então, portanto, conhecer a
origem da alimentação do animal é muito
importante, sim, para reduzir os riscos.
Então essa história que você falou da
doença da vaca louca, que o surgimento
estaria relacionado ao uso de farinha de
carne e osso de animais infectados. É
verdade isso?
Tá? Então também práticas similares
podem acontecer se você alimentar porcos
com proteías de origem animal, não
tratar de forma térmica. né? Isso ainda
pode desencadear problemas de saúde
pública. Então, desde 96 no Brasil tem
proibições rigorosas quanto ao uso desse
subprodutos na alimentação de
ruminantes, né? Então isso é uma medida
que reduziu drasticamente os casos da
doença. E no Brasil você tem uma um
rigor muito grande por causa da
exportação, né?
Então é importante ter cautela ao
consumir carne de porco, especialmente
quando a origem alimentação do
animal eh são incertas, tá? Então tem
que ficar muito atento quanto a isso,
tem razão. E sempre optar por produtos
inspecionados, priorizar sistemas de
criação éticos e diversificar a dieta
com fontes proteicas vegetais desses
animais. São medidas que aliam segurança
alimentar, saúde individual e
sustentabilidade. Próxima
pergunta.
Eu tô achando estranho que não tem
ninguém acompanhando ao vivo. Será que
eu tô ao vivo
mesmo? Não, aparentemente eu tô ao
vivo. Bem, vamos continuar
aqui. Dr. Alan, você disse que a veina
protege o cérebro. É capaz também de
tratar ou talvez até curar doenças
cerebrais. Eh, tem o poder de maximizar
a potência cerebral. Qual a dose para
proteger o
cérebro? Então, a beberina, ela tem sim
efeitos neuroprotetores e
metabólicos. Ela atua no cérebro através
de múltiplos mecanismos. Ela reduz a
inflamação neuronal, combate estresse
oxidativo, inibe a agregação de
proteínas betamides associadas Alzheimer
e protege os neurônios após eventos
isquêmicos como AVC. Então, pesquisa em
modelos
animais, ah, mostraram que a substância,
né, berberina, melhora a memória
espacial e reconhecimento, aumenta a
placidade sináptica e estimula a
produção de fatores neutrópico, como
BDNF, né, o brain derived
neutropicor. A dosagem geralmente que a
gente recomenda é 500 a 1500 mg de área.
A dose mais comum é 500 mg duas vezes ao
dia. Pode ser dividido esses 500 mg em
duas a três
tomadas 30 minutos antes das
refeições. É interessante personalizar
zoolologia sempre com acompanhamento
médico, principalmente para quem já faz
uso de remédio para pressão, diabetes ou
anticoagulantes. Então, em casos
específicos como prevenção de sequela
pós AVC, estudos utilizaram eh
equivalentes eh humanos de 50 a 100 mg
por kg dia em modelos
animais. A bina, ela potencializa a
combinição através da inibição da
acetilcolinesterase, que é a enzima que
quebra a
citilcolina. Então, aumentando a
citilcolina, você tem mais memória. E
também ela tem uma ação muito
interessante no intestino, modulando o
microbioma intestinal.
e também ajuda a regular a
glicemia. Não temos evidências ainda do
uso da beberina para curar do
neurodegenerativas, mas a supmentação da
beberina ajuda bastante sim associado a
um estilo de vida anti-inflamatório. OK?
E é interessante você associar a bebina
com outros
neuroprotetores, como é o caso, né, da
ômega-3,
curcumina,
esveratrol, também
serrata, colina e vários outros, né?
A minha mãe de 96 anos foi diagnosticada
com anemia e foi recitado o ferro, mas o
efeito colateral é diarreia. Pode tomar
algo para eliminar esse
efeito? É bem comum as pessoas terem
diarreia com uso do ferro, tá?
Porque o ferro ele pode causar uma
irritação na mocose do estômago do
intestino. Em dos efeitos geralmente é
mais comum e mais
incômodo. Então para minimizar essa
diarreia causada pelo ferro existe
algumas estratégias que você pode ser
utilizadas, tá? Primeiro, você pode
ajustar a forma de administração do
suplemento. Então, fórmulas como ferro,
bisglicinato são menos agressivas ao
epité do intestino, tem melhor
absorção e permite às vezes você reduzir
a dose
necessária. Outra opção, você dividir a
dose de área em quantidades menores ao
longo do dia, tomando junto com as
refeições para diminuir a irritação do
estômago. E se essas medidas não forem
suficientes, você pode também optar por
administração de ferro por via
intravenosa ou intramuscular, né, que
evita completamente o trato do
gastrointestinal, é indicado para
pacientes com intolerância grave aos
comprimidos.
Então, para pessoas que têm diarreia com
uso do ferro, é importante reforçar a
hidratação para compensar a perda de
líquido. Água de coco é uma opção
natural, tem muitos eletrólitos, ajuda a
repous minerais essenciais, inclui
também alimentos ricos em ferro de fácil
absorção, como carne vermelha,
beterraba, folha verde escura e associar
a fontes de vitamina CO de laranja e
limão, que eu comentei na outra
pergunta, porque a vitamina C
potencializa a absorção do
ferro, evitar o café, o chá preto, chá,
chá preto, café e laticínios, né, que
vai diminuir a absorção do ferro
também. E para pessoas que t diarré
também, outra intervenção interessante
seria equilibrar cloro
intestinal com uso de
probióticos e também
utilizar eh alimentos fermentados,
quefir, iogurte fermentado, pode ajudar.
chá de camomila, eh, chá de folha de
goiaba, também tem propriedades
antiispasmóticas,
antiinflamatórias e é normal que as fees
fiquem escuras com uso do ferro. Então,
ficar atento quanto a isso, tá? Também
podem ficar
esverdeadas, mas se a diarrea continuar
a ficar persistente ou tiver sangue ou
muco tem que porar assistência
médica, ok?
Dr. Alan, é verdade que as galinhas
geneticamente modificadas, elas não
podem ser deixadas ao ar livre, comendo
o resto de comida insertos. Deve ser
insetos, né? Como a galinha caipira,
pois ela acaba adoecendo. Se isso for
verdade, na sua opinião, essas galinhas
geneticamente modificadas são aberrações
da natureza.
Os efeitos negativos delas na saúde
humana já foram totalmente estudados.
Garinhas caipiras são mais resistentes à
gripe aviária e demais
doenças. Então isso aí é uma pergunta
difícil de responder, né? Essa questão
das garinhas geneticamente
modificadas é uma questão muito
complexa. Eh, tem vários fatores aí
técnicos, ecológicos, éticos,
né? Então, temos que diferenciar
primeiro as galinhas geneticamente
modificadas das caipidas, né? As
primeiras são alteradas em laboratório
para expressar características
específicas como crescimento acelerado
ou resistenciar a patógenos. Enquanto as
caipiras são variedades tradicionais
criadas sistemas mais naturais com
acesso à pastagem da alimentação
diversificada. Então, quanto essa
afirmação que você fez que as galinhas
geneticamente modificadas não podem ser
criadas ao ar livre sem a 2C, isso é
parcialmente verdade, tá?
Muitas linha modificadas foram
selecionadas para maximizar a
produtividade de ambientes controlados,
né, aquele sistema confinamento, o que
torna elas sim vulneráveis a variações
ambientais, a estresse, agentes
infecciosos que podem sair de controle
quando a galinha tá sendo criado em
ambiente externo, né, ou
aberto. Então, essas galinhas
modificadas geneticamente geralmente não
tem um sistema imune tão desenvolvido
quanto das galinhas caipirilhas, né,
devido a esse foco genético em
características como ganho de peso ou
produção de ovos.
Isso geralmente em detrimento de
mecanismos naturais de defesa. Então
issos comparativos mostram que as
galinhas de perus, aves
comerciais eh dessas aí modificadas
acumulam maiores cargas virais de gripe
aviária em órgãos vitais, incluindo o
cérebro, quando elas são infectadas e ao
contrário de espécies ancestrais, né,
que não tem esse essa situação. OK?
Além disso, a exposição a restos de
comida ou insetos em ambientes não
controlados aumenta o risco de
contaminação por toxinas e patógenos, já
que essas aves não têm um sistema imune
tão bem desenvolvido, não tem também a
mesma capacidade de detox do que as
galinhas
caipidas. Essa questão de ser
considerada como aberrações da natureza
é uma avaliação subjetiva, né? Isso não
é uma coisa exatamente científica.
vai depender do seu ponto de vista. Do
ponto de vista de alguns cientistas, a
modificação genética é uma ferramenta
que replica processos naturais de
mutação, porém de forma dirigida. Então,
críticos, como parece seu caso, né,
argumentam que a intervenção humana em
espécies animais, sem a compressão total
das consequências em cadeia, vai gerar
desequilíbrios em ecossistemas e vai
gerar dependência de insumos
industriais. como rações específicas ou
medicamentos. Então, tem a situação de
pesquisas com cabras e peixes
alimentados com transgênicos, em que foi
detectado fragmentos de DNA modificado
nos seus tecidos e indicando que
alterações genéticas podem ter efeitos
imprevistos ao longo da cadeia
alimentar.
Então existem ainda lacunas, né, sobre o
entendimento dos transgênicos na saúde
humana.
Estudos preliminares associam o consumo
de produtos geneticamente modificados ou
derivados de animais geneticamente
modificados, alterações metabólicas e
potenciais riscos como aumento de
enzimas hepáticas e possíveis
interferências em processos
celulares. Além disso, esses animais
geralmente são modificados para ter
tolerância ao uso de herbicidas, como o
linfosato, que tá muito vinculado a
cultivos transgênicos.
E o glicosato, o linfosato já foi
associado a malformações embriões de
vertebrados e leva preocupações muito
importante sobre o resíduo desse
agrotóxo nos
alimentos. E tem evidência que as
galinhas caipiras criadas no sistema de
criação extensivo tem o sistema imune
mais forte do que as galinhas
geneticamente modificadas que estão em
ambientes fechados, tá?
As aves criadas em ar livre desenvolvem
uma microbiota intestinal mais variada e
mais robusta, o que tá ligado a melhores
respostas
imunes. Porém, não quer dizer que essas
galinhas estejam imunes à gripe aviária.
Ainda é um risco, tá? O vírus
H5N1, ele é altamente contagioso, ele é
tal, pode pegar essas galinhas, mesmo
elas sendo mais
resistentes. Então tem que ficar atento
quanto a
isso. Banho gelado tem o poder de
prevenir doenças graves como câncer, das
artérias e AVC, aumenta a imunidade, a
[Música]
imunidade. O banho
gelado, se você fizer ele alternado com
a
sauna, ele cria um choque, né, que
aumenta um tipo de proteína específica,
tá? que são as
chaperonas ou hitck
proteins. E isso tem sim respostas
fisiológicas benéficas, porque quando
você tem esse choque térmico aumentando
hitap protein ou
chaperona, isso tem efeito positivo no
organismo causando aumento de cirtuínas
que tende a aumentar a longevidade, tá?
Mas os estudos quanto a isso ainda não
estão totalmente definidos.
Existe estudos mostrando que a exposição
controlada ao frio pode contribuir para
melhorar vários aspectos de saúde, mas
isso tá ainda sendo estudado com mais
intensidade. Além da questão das
cirtoínas, das chaperonas, o choque
térmico também pode aumentar a produção
de leucoston células de defesa e pode
reduzir uns processos inflamatórios
crônicos.
Então, tá faltando ainda evidências
conclusivas de que a prática previna
diretamente
doenças. Então, a gente trata isso como
adjuvante, né, ou coadjuvante em
estratégias mais amplas.
Existe evidências que eh quando você faz
o choque térmico, né, você faz a
artério, vaso constrição e vaso
dilatação através do calor e
frio, isso melhora a circulação
sanguínea e isso pode a melhorar a
oxigenação do tecido quando você passa
de uma situação do gelo que causa vaso
constrição pro calor que vaza que causa
vaso dilatação.
Só que pessoas que têm risco
cardiovascular muito alto, tem que ter
cautela com essa questão do choque
térmico, porque pode eh elevar
temporariamente a pressão arterial e a
frequência cardíaca.
Então, na visão da medicina funcional, a
exposição ao frio é considerado um
estresse positivo, que a gente chama de
ormese, é a mesma coisa que acontece com
a atividade física, tá? ou
comxona, porque ele é capaz de induzir
adaptações metabólicas e fortalecer a
resiliência do
organismo. Mas comece devagar para você
fazer isso com segurança, comece com
banhos curtos, né, gelados, tá?
30 a 60 segundos na água fria e não
gelada de início para você aumentando
gradativamente a exposição e se
acostumar com esse processo. Pessoas que
têm pressão alta ou que tem doença
cardíaca ou pessoas que frio devem
consultar primeiro o médico antes,
porque a vaso constrição aguda pode
desencadear complicações. OK?
Próxima pergunta
aqui. Para evitar a gripe quieta, você
indicou a água e abacate ou sais
minerais? Sim,
exatamente, né? Ou não, água, abacate e
sais minerais.
Os sais minerais substitui o
abacate? É mais ou menos, tá? Porque o
abacate tem sais
minerais, mas o abacate tem outras
coisas boas também que não são
substituíveis por sais minerais,
tá? Como faço o pedido da
integritar? Então, a gente recomenda o
abacate porque ele é rico em potássio,
rico em magnésio, rico em gorduras
saudáveis, entende? Então ele tem muita
caloria saudável, tem esses minerais
saudáveis, tem várias vitaminas boas
também. Então ele ajuda a repor
nutrientes e minimizar a fadiga e câra
do quetoflu, né, da gripe quetogênica.
Então, né, que o abacate vai ser
altamente substituível por sais minerais
como sódio, potássio e magnésio,
mas ele vai também atuar nesse
sentido. Mas os site minerais não vão
ter fibras, não vão ter as vitaminas e
não vou ter a gordura saudável e nem
compostos antiinflamatórios.
Em relação à farmácia integritar, você
pode solicitar um blend de eletrólos
cetogênicos. Então você pode procurar
por fórmulas que tem 300 a 500 mg de
magnésio bisglicinato, 1000 a 2000 mg de
potássio na forma de cloreto e 2000 a
3000 mg de sódio, que pode ser na forma
de sal rosa ou sal integral.
Então você pode tá adicionando 1/4 de
colher de chá desse pó, né, dessa
mistura de magnésio,
potássio e sal
integral em 500 ml de água e consumir
isso ao longo do dia. E para
potencializar, você pode incluir
alimentos como espinafre, que tem muito
magnésio e sementes de abóbora que tem
bastante zinco. OK.
Maria Helena, antigos diziam existir
comidas remosas. Isso quer dizer o
dururoso, tá? Isso é verdade. Se sim,
quais os perigos que atinge o organismo
humano? Tá? Eu entendi a palavra remoso
como gorduroso, tá? Mas pode significar
também, especialmente na região norte e
nordeste como comidas fortes ou
inflamatórias, tá? Então esta
classificação inclui carne de porco,
carne de pato, fruto do mar, embutido,
frituras em geral, açúcar, bebida
alcoólica e alimentos
ultraprocessados. E a crença popular,
ela afirma que esses alimentos remodos
poderiam prejudicar a cicatrização de
feridas.
agravar inflamações ou causar reações
como coceiras e erupções na pele, tá?
Então existe assim uma sabedoria popular
nisso, porque vários desses alimentos
que a gente comentou aqui, não todos,
especialmente na visão da medicina
funcional integrativa, eles reconhecem
como tendo características sim
pró-inflamatórias, né, como é o caso de
carne processada, como é o carne de caso
de algumas frituras, né, que usa óleo de
semente
processado. Esses compostos poderiam
estar estimulando vias inflamatórias no
organismo. Alimentos industrializados
como aditivos químicos, né, e com
aditivos químicos e xarope de milho vão
interferir na flora intestinal e vão
desencadear femilidade intestinal
exagerada, né, ou
liquidgat e respostas imunes
exacerbadas. OK?
Então é recomendado substituir alimentos
remotos, né, por alternativas
antiinflamatórias, né, proteína de peixe
selvagem, de ave caipira, de oleaginosa,
de sementes, de carne de pasto, carne de
um gado que pastou,
né, usar os superalimentos, as
especiarias como cúrcum e gengibre que
ajudam na inflamação, probióticos,
vitamina C, zinco, tudo isso nós
conversamos já, né?
Próxima pergunta. Autismo tem cura? O
que causa o autismo? Na sua opinião? A
causa do autismo é multifatorial, tá?
Falar em cura é muito difícil. Pode
falar
em alguns casos são simreversíveis a o
autismo, mas é uma coisa bem incomum,
tá? Menos de 5%.
A maioria dos casos você consegue
melhorar bastante os sintomas do
autismo, mas não chega a curar,
tá? Só para vocês lembrarem, né? O TEA,
que é o transtorno do espectro autista,
é uma condição que afeta o
neurodesenvolvimento, especialmente a
comunicação, a interação social e o
comportamento. A visão mais moderna não
que é uma doença específica, tá? Mas é
uma variação neurológica. complexa que
pode se manifestar de várias maneiras
diferentes e
únicas. E é uma doença extremamente
complexa ou é uma condição extremamente
complexa, né, como eu acabei de falar,
não é mais considerada uma doença e é
influenciado por um conjunto muito amplo
de problemas, pode ser genéticos,
ambientais, pode ser radiação, pode ser
toxinas, pode ser microbioma intestinal.
alterado, pode ser metal pesado, pode
ser pulantes
orgânicos. Então é muito complexo a a
situação. Tem alguns estudos genéticos
que identificaram mutações espontâneas e
heranças familiares associadas ao TEEA,
mas não são todos os casos. Tem também
situações de variações no cromossomo X,
né? tem uma doença parecida com o
autismo, que é o síndrome do X frágil,
comete só
meninos. E tem algumas síndrométicas
também que tem o autismo tea como parte
da da constelação de sintomas,
né? Existe também alguns estudos
mostrando esse equilíbrio de
neurotransmissores como serotonina e
dopamina no cérebro das crianças
autistas.
também evidências de que essas crianças
passaram por inflamações durante a
gestação. Já falei disposição às
toxinas. Complicações no parto também
são fatores que podem estar
interferindo. Deficiências nutricionais,
especialmente deficiência de iodo e
ômega-3 tem relação com isso também de
vitamina D de
dado. Em embora são suspeitas e nenhum
fator isolado explique totalmente o
autismo. OK?
Tem a questão da vacina, que é muito
discutido, é considerado
tabu e que a medicina ortodoxa considera
como um mito, mas a gente não considera
dentro da medicina funcional, a gente
leva a sério essa relação entre vacina e
TEA.
Apesar de que eu não tô dizendo para
vocês não vacinar os seus filhos, mas
tomem muito cuidado com a quantidade de
vacinas que é feita no mesmo
ano e deixa a vitamina D esse essas
crianças em nível adequados para fazer a
vacinação. A abordagem hoje moderna do
TEIA é a associação de mudança e estilo
de vida com terapia comportamental, ABA,
fonudiólogo, terapia
ocupacional, acompanhamento,
acompanhamento
pedagógico, uso do cannabis de algumas
crianças que tm agitação ou
agressividade, que antigamente eles
usavam neuroléticos, mas eu não
recomendo a nutrição mais limpa
possível, né, com alimentos
antiinflamatórios, cortando glút
leite e derivad, suplementação adequada
de vitamina D, B12 nos minerais, né, com
magnésio
zinco. Tentar colocar as crianças para
praticar mindfulness nesse yoga,
meditação, OK? E modular o microbioma
intestinal.
Vi você dizer que a dieta citogênica não
ajudava na depressão e no
TDH. Ué, entendi
não. Eu falei que a dieta fitogênica não
ajudava na depressão. Eu acho que você
entendeu
errado. Ajuda
sim. Mas depois vi você dizer que a
dieta desinflama o céu. Sim. Eu não sei
quando é que eu falei isso não. Você tá
falando aí, eu acho que eu não falei
isso
não. Talvez você não ter entendido
direito o que eu
falei. A a dieta cetogênica, ela é
antiinflamatória sim, porque ela quando
você reduz o consumo de carboidratos e
aumenta as gorduras saudáveis e se induz
o corpo a um a um estado cetótico, né,
de cetose leve.
E a utilização dos corpos cetônicos como
principal fonte de energia pelo cérebro
tem um impacto anti-inflamatório no
cérebro, sim, porque ele vai evitar o
estresse
oxidativo, tá? Então, se você entendeu
algum momento que eu falei que a
dietogênica não era boa para depressão,
eu não, talvez eu tenha dito que não
cura a depressão, aí é outra história,
tá? Ela ajuda sim, mas ela não cura
sozinha a
depressão. A resistência insulínica
cerebral, ela tá associada sim à
depressão. Tem um componente
inflamatório na
depressão. Tem um estudo que foi
publicado em 2024 com uma série de casos
que
relatou remissão completa de depressão e
ansiedade em pacientes após 7 a 12
semanas de terapia metabólica cetogênica
rigorosa. É pouco a gente consegue fazer
isso com a melhora paralela de
parâmetros como sono, energia e função
[Música]
cognitiva. em modelos animais, a dieta
citogênica, ela mostrou a redução de
comportamentos depressivos e melhora da
plasticidade
neuronal. E no
TDH, a estabilização dos níveis de
açúcar no sangue, que é promovido pela
cetose, pode ajudar a regular os níveis
de dopamina, que é o neurotransmissor
crítico na atenção e
motivação. OK?
Tá lembrando que eu nunca falei que a
dieta citogênica cura a depressão, tá?
Ela é uma ferramenta muito importante
que ajuda bastante.
OK. Ah, Dra. Ol, vi uma pessoa
falando que a nicotina traz benefícios
para a saúde, para a concentração,
inclusive. Então, é porque tem uma
diferença entre a nicotina do cigarro e
a nicotina
como remédio, tá? E sim, ela tem sido
estudado já há alguns anos
como um possível agente noópico com
efeitos cognitivos interessantes, tá? Eu
entendo que você associe a nicotina aos
malefícios do cigarro, mas entenda que a
nicotina é só uma das milhares de
substâncias que tem no tabaco, tá?
Então, na verdade, o cigarro faz muito
mais mal por conta das toxinas eh
ligadas à queima do tabaco e ao papel do
que necessariamente a nicotina. A
nicotina, na verdade, é um fármaco, tá?
Quando você usa a nicotina de forma
isolada e administra de uma maneira
controlada, ela pode sim ter benefícios
para a função de concentração em
memória. Então a nicotina pura, ela
estimula
receptores que são os nicotínicos que
são ligados à cetoculina. Então esse
neurotransmissor acilicolina é crucial
para processos cognitivos. Então pode
melhorar a tensão a velocidade de
processamento cerebral e até fornecer
uma proteção para doenças
degenerativas. Só que só utilizar a
nicotina na forma medicamentosa e não
utilizar através de cigarros ou
dispositivos como vapors, né, os
vaporizadores. OK?
[Música]
Então, o uso de nicotina pura em baixas
doses é sim um modulador cognitivo
interessante, especialmente em caso de
déficit de atenção que não tem um
diagnóstico formal. OK?
Só que tem que tomar cuidado porque a
nicotina também pode ter um potencial de
dependência. Tem efeitos colaterais com
aumento da pressão arterial, porque ele
dá
vasoconstricção, pode dar alterações no
ritmo cardíaco, pode ter impacto
negativo na saúde vascular. Então tem
que tomar muito cuidado de usar por
pouco tempo a nicotina.
E dentro da medicina funcional,
geralmente a gente não utiliza muito ele
não. Dr. Alan, na manhã está nublado.
Ficar exposto no ar livre, mesmo sem
sol, traz o benefício para melhorar a o
sono de
noite? Sim, sim. Vale a pena você se
expor ao ar livre durante a manhã e ao
sol mesmo em dias dublados,
tá? Porque mesmo que o sol não esteja
assim incendido de uma maneira muito
intensa, você vai ter a a luminosidade
natural que vai ajudar a modular a
melatonina mesmo sendo filtrada pelas
nuvens.
A luminosidade, mesmo de dias nublados,
vai ativar receptores específicos na
retina que sincronizam o nosso relógio
biológico e regulam a produção de
cortisol e também de melatonina. OK? Tem
uns estudos da Universidade de
Washington que demonstram que cada hora
de exposição à luz de urna, mesmo em
dias cinzas, adianta o ritmo cicadiano
em 30
minutos. Isso facilita o adormecer. Eu
mesmo melhor quando eu fico ao ar livre
durante várias horas do dia. A luz
natural, especialmente a luz azul
natural, ela suprime a melatonina
durante o dia, mas aumenta a produção à
noite,
tá? Então tente ficar pelo menos 30
minutos ao ar livre pela manhã, se for
possível, ok? Combinando com a atividade
física
leve, você diz que existem cânceres que
se alimentam de glicosea, mas tem outros
que se alimentam de gordura. Como fica a
dieta cidogênica nesse caso? Boa
pergunta. Boa pergunta. O que eu quis
dizer é o seguinte, né? Segundo as
teorias
lá, né, que até hoje são muito faladas
de que o câncer se alimenta de
glicose, através das teorias do Dr.
Wberg, né?
Isso era bem válido, mas tem alguns
casos de câncer específicos que se
alimentam
sim de corpos cetônicos. São exceções,
tá?
Felizmente são
exceções. Então, a dieta ela vai sim eh
ser útil no tratamento de vários
cânceres como estratégia
complementar, mas o efeito dela vai
depender do perfil metabólico do tumor.
Como eu falei, a maioria dos tumores são
sim dependentes de glicose, mas já
existe estudos mostrando que alguns
tumores se alimentam sim de copos
cetônicos, tá?
Então, o princípio do efeito
Warberg é que a maioria dos cânceres
utiliza a glicose como principal fonte
de energia e a dietogênica pode privar
essas células cancerosas do seu
combustível preferido, possando um
estado de fome metabólica e gerando essa
morte das células cancerígenas. Enquanto
que os cetônicos produzidos pelo
processamento das gorduras com beta
hidróxidirato, serve como energia
alternativa para as células
saudáveis. Isso tem bastante evidência
em estudos em gliomas, que é um tipo de
tumor cerebral, e
neuroblastoma, em em que essa abordagem
reduz o crescimento moral e aumenta a
eficácia da radioterapia. Mas tem certos
tipos de câncer, de pâncreas, de mama,
de próstata que desenvolvem sim a
capacidade de usar gordura como energia
principal, tá? Pâncreas, mão e próstata.
Então, nesses casos, a tetogênica,
isoladamente não funcionaria
para suprimir esses
tumores. Mas existem pesquisas
interessantes recentes que mostram uma
estratégia muito inteligente de combinar
a dieta cetogênica com medicamentos que
bloqueiam especificamente metabolismo de
gorduras nas células cancerosas. Então
você pode pegar da célula da a dieta
cetogênica junto com medicamentos que
bloqueiam a absorção de gordura pelas
células cancerosas. Dessa maneira você
vai enganar o tumor, fazendo ele
depender só novamente de
glicose, forçando então ele só utilizar
a glicose. Então você vai ter esse
benefício metabólico de de utilizar a
dieta cetogênica.
Em modelos animais de câncer de
pâncreas, a combinação do medicamento
que
bloqueia a a utilização de gordura pela
célula tumoral com a dieta quetogênica,
reduziu os tumores em até
50%. Tem alguns tumores que têm
plasticidade metabólica e conseguem
alternar entre glicose e gordura
dependendo da disponibilidade, tá?
Então, para esses casos, a abordagem
funcional sugere protocolos
cíclicos, fazendo um choque metabólico,
então fazer períodos de cetos rigorosas
e intercalados com fase de reintrodução
controlada de carboidratos. Então fica
alternando dieta com carboidrato
complexo com dieta cetogênica, tá? Isso
sempre monitorado com exames de sangue
que avaliam os níveis de glicose,
cetonas e marcadoras tumorais. Então tem
estudos preliminares que sugerem que
essa oscilação intencional confunde as
células cancerosas e prejudica a
adaptação delas elas são flexíveis aos
dos
combustíveis. Tem alguns suplementos que
potencializam o a dieta citogênica nos
seus efeitos antitumorais. é o caso do
ácido alfao, é o caso da berberina que
vão ajudar a reduzir a resistência à
insulina, é o caso do ômega-3 que vai
modular a
inflamação. Eh, pacientes que estão em
uso de quimioterapia podem receber
variações na dieta com moderado teor
proteico para preservar massa muscular,
que é um fator crítico no
prognóstico. Interessante que tem
pesquisas em câncer de mama triplo
negativo que mostraram que a cetose
poderia estimular a metástase, seria o
contrário, tá? Nesse caso específico de
câncer de mama triplo negativo, tá? Eh,
mas em alguns
subtipos, porque tem uma proteína nessa
nesse tipo de câncer aí que é o
BACH1, que promove a migração celular. E
isso, eh, nesses casos, a dieta
citogênica não adiantaria.
Então isso justifica você fazer
avaliações genômicas antes de iniciar a
dieta cetogênica. Nesse caso é do tubor
de câncer de mama triplo
negativo. Existe também um protocolo
muito interessante que você combina
carboidratos cardanos, que é o caso de
você tá utilizando carboidratos
complexos consumidos apenas no jantar e
não outros momentos do dia. Isso vai
sincronizar a oferta de glicose com o
ritmo natural de reparo celular. Então
essa abordagem continua mantendo a
cetose de manhã cedo enquanto fornece
substrato para a imunidade noturna, tá?
Essa é uma estratégia também muito
interessante, só que essa dieta exige um
monitoramento bem
rigoroso e o ideal é você manter, se
você puder medir o beta hidróxidirato no
sangue, manter entre 2 e 4 milimoles
para tá induzindo essa cetose matinal.
Tá? Então, na verdade, tem que ser visto
caso a caso. A dieta fitogênica não é um
remédio único para todos. A aplicação do
câncer tem que ser individualizada e de
preferência mapeamento metabólico do
tumor, um ajuste nutrigenômico,
integração com terapias convencionais,
tá? E hoje em dia eu tenho utilizado a
evictina também nesses casos. Bem,
pessoal, temos mais uma hora de live. Eu
vou encerrar aqui porque hoje não teve
nenhuma interação aqui
no, não sei se algum bug aqui do
sistema, mas eu não vi nenhum comentário
de boa noite, não vi comentário nenhum
hoje, mas já me disseram que a
professora Denise falou que tá
acompanhando, ela falou aqui do
WhatsApp. Bem pessoal, muito obrigado
pela atenção de vocês e nós nos vemos na
semana que vem. Abraço, um beijo no
coração de todos vocês.